am I in for here let's go keep it think
it'll
no I make me feel I better girl but it's
causing me shame you meet girls all the
time no no SS
cause any pain this one's different I
come from such different world lately
star but I've never felt this way about
anybody feel it gets good
would you still have me up and down what
I've ever done anything like this before
we are sure that what I just came to
drop this off don't you get that from
your car I haven't been able to read
these four years you want me to read
them to you April tense and the face of
burning hey my dearest Ruth I remember
that Percy war even when I forgotten my
own name I wish I could take a little
all be happily ever after not everybody
gets that
you did
was that simple Luke you need to stop or
next time you're more likely gonna pick
him up at the morgue this is my life
it's all I know I can't be with someone
if every time they walk out the door I
don't know if I'm gonna see them again
hanus need to come back
I still not to make this work
love requires sacrifice
but it's worth it